family law is like the number one reason
why you should never get married i'm not
saying don't have kids i'm not saying
don't have a relationship with a woman
or women whatever your game happens to
be i'm not saying any of those things
all i'm saying is don't ever live in a
way that invites the government to
decide what happens to your kids to your
assets to your cash to your investments
to your retirement fund to your cars
planes boats and motorcycles whatever
toys you might own businesses any kind
of business income any kind of business
assets
all of that stuff
why why would you want to complicate
your life unnecessarily i had this
conversation you know with my lawyer
after i got divorced we've gotten
together for lunch a few times he's a
good guy
um he's watched a few of my podcasts
actually
and uh text me on them but
you know i asked him the same question
that people often ask me rich would you
ever get married he said no there's i
don't see any benefits in it he goes
i've res i've resigned myself to being a
lifelong bachelor that's just the way
that i'm going to be and he's got a
girlfriend and they live in separate
homes and he's happy with his life and
if she doesn't like that he lets her go
and he just replaces her right
far far too many guys
get far too attached to
ego investments that they make
in women and relationships
uh you know sugar and spice and all
things nice blah blah blah one of the
things people always say is uh well who
are you gonna get to take care of you if
you're sick it's like my girlfriend
you know you don't need to get married
to have somebody to take care of you if
you get sick
right like what kind of weak-ass guy is
that you know if you've got money and
you're a competent guy you can hire a
nurse it doesn't matter who's gonna take
care of you if you get sick
nurse isn't gonna take half your [ __ ] if
you hire to take care of you while
you're sick
do i really need to get that deep
how deep do i need to get in a family
law you guys ask questions in the chat
i'll i'll i'll keep an eye open for the
questions in the chat
and uh
see if there's anything you want me to
dive deep in when it comes to
these notions that i'm presenting to you
anyway there's three other ones that i
want to get into
and then i want to pop up this uh
married man blog that i found that was
hilarious domestic violence is another
very very real threat if a woman is
unhappy with you
and one of the things you have to
understand guys is women always reserve
the right to change their mind at any
given time
right that's
female nature right they
they just are that way
okay um
unconditional love is is one of the
demands that men seem to have of women
in relationships which is a farce
her love is conditional
it is entirely conditional
on you providing something
um
whether it's resources or attention
but only women this is chris rockline by
the way only women children and dogs are
loved unconditionally men are only loved
under the condition that they provide
something
right
so if a woman changes her mind about you
and recognizes that domestic violence
that a alleged domestic violence even
not even domestic violence but alleged a
lot of the times it's women cornering
men and and
imposing themselves i've i've talked to
guys that have had knives thrown at them
uh jars glass jars like
mason jars or like jam jars you know
stuff like that
i talked to a guy that got stabbed in
the leg um once by a woman um this dude
was going through a divorce he hired me
for some coaching and it's like
women will sometimes do violent things
and they don't even need to do violent
things
they just have to allege that she's
scared of you and then the cops can you
know she'll make a phone call
cops are called they come over pick you
up you're locked out of your house
i have a friend that um
got removed from his house
his wife cheated on him
and uh she started you know during the
whole divorce process and the separation
period was acting
very very
like provocatively in the sense that she
was trying to create uh chaos and havoc
you know between them
uh you know to escalate the situation
and she was lying about something to do
with the cheating uh you know he caught
her cheating
and he just shook his finger in her face
just like and called her a lot he said
you're a [ __ ] liar like that and that
was enough to get him removed from his
own house and away from his kids
right
domestic violence is no [ __ ] joke
i'd like to talk about ways to
minimize these risks i'm going to look
at the comments for that towards the end
of the show but seriously domestic
violence is no [ __ ] joke and if you
live in a way that the state see deems
as a marriage
there are there's there's advantageous
things that a woman can do
to benefit her financially
from a control perspective
from a power perspective
uh by just alleging it it doesn't even
have to happen okay
just be aware of that there's lots of
stories out there um i've told another
one before where a guy came home from
work
and she was on the phone he basically
walked in the front door and she was on
the phone with the police going yeah he
just got here and i'm terrified and he's
threatening to hurt me
and
15 12 minutes later two cruisers come
flying down the street one up on his
lawn tears up his grass picks them up
takes them off right
alleged domestic violence is all that's
required so
if you're living
in such a way that the government sees
as
uh marriage whether you've declared
you know
your your your vows in front of a
priest church
you know at the courthouse whatever way
you decide to do it at the drive-thru in
vegas with the elvis priest
whatever way you decide to do it if you
live in such a way that applies
family law which can be used with
domestic violence you're exposing
yourself to risk unnecessarily remember
marriage is very high reward low risk
for women but for men it's high risk and
low reward and i'm going to talk about
some of those low reward issues in a bit
as we kind of dive down through this but
let's keep moving on um actually let me
just pause over here on my notes and
just go up a little bit because there
was a couple of questions i saw that
looked interesting
how about dying alone everybody dies
alone bro
everybody i look i know
probably three or four people that died
in the last year and they all died alone
like in stupid ways like i even said
like at one point like i can't believe
this is how people go right like by
themselves in a [ __ ] hospital nobody
can come and see you and it's like
that's it right everybody dude everybody
dies alone that's like one of the
biggest like
crybaby betta ass reasons that i hear
guys get married because they don't want
to die alone
everybody dies alone
you think you're getting lying there in
bed holding hands with your wife your
girlfriend your long-term partner
whatever the hell you want to call him
singing kumbaya and you both die
simultaneously it doesn't work that way
dad got arrested and pulled from his
house he did nothing wrong yeah like
i know guys that have that have like
they've been taken away and they come
back and there's long-standing
consequences to that too i know a guy
that is unable to obtain
uh firearms in his state anymore because
of a false domestic violence allegation
right
so what do you got to do he's got to
move states like that's really the only
only way that you can deal with that
it's it's
it's crazy it's crazy right hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you